and i think if you look at the long arc
of history i suspect that the things
that will be remembered is the
philosophical flavor of the ideas
of physics and chemistry and computer
science and mathematics
like i think the actual details
will be shown to be incomplete or maybe
wrong
but the philosophical intuitions will
carry through much longer
there's a sense in which if it's true
that we haven't figured out
most of how things work currently
that uh it'll all be shown as wrong and
silly it'd almost be a historical
artifact
but the the human spirit whatever like
the the longing to understand the the
way we perceive the world the way we
conceive of it
uh of our place in the world those those
ideas will carry on
i completely agree in fact i believe
that uh almost
well i believe that none of the
principles or laws of physics we know
today are exactly correct
all of them are approximations to
something they are better than the
previous versions that we had but
none of them are exactly correct and
none of them are going to stand forever
so i agree that that's the process we
are heading we are improving
and yes indeed the thought process and
that philosophical take
is common so when we look at you know
older
scientists or maybe even all the way
back to greek philosophers and the
things that the way they thought and so
on
almost everything they said about you
know nature was incorrect
but the way they thought about it and
many things that they were thinking
is still valid today for example they
thought about symmetry breaking
they were trying to explain the
following they were this is a beautiful
example i think
they had figured out that the earth is
round and they said okay earth is around
they have you know they have seen the
length of the shadow of this meter stick
and they have seen that if you go from
the equator
upwards north they find that depending
on how far away you are the length of
the shadow changes and from that they
have either they had even measured the
radius of the earth
to good accuracy that's brilliant by the
way the fact that they did that
very brilliant very busy so these greek
philosophers were very smart and so
uh they had taken it to the next step
they asked okay so the earth is round
why doesn't it move they thought it
doesn't move they they were looking
around nothing seemed to move so
so they said okay we have to have a good
explanation it wasn't enough for them to
you know be there so they really want to
deeply understand that fact
and they come up with a symmetry
argument and the symmetry argument was
oh if the earth is a spherical it must
be at the center of the universe for
sure so they said the earth is at the
center of the universe it makes sense
and they said you know if earth is going
to move which direction does it pick
any direction it picks it breaks that
spherical symmetry because you have to
pick a direction
and that's not good because it's not
symmetrical anymore so therefore
the earth decides to sit put because it
would break the symmetry
so so they had the incorrect science
they thought earth doesn't move and they
but they had this beautiful idea that
symmetry might explain it
but they were even smarter than that
aristotle didn't agree with this
argument
he said why do you think symmetry
prevents it from moving because the
preferred position
not so he gave an example he said
suppose
you are a person and you put we put you
at the center of a circle
and we spread food around you on a
circle around you
loaves of bread let's say and we say
okay
stay at the center of the circle forever
are you going to do that just because of
the symmetric point
no you're going to get hungry you're
going to move towards one of those
levels of bread
despite the fact that it breaks the
symmetry so from this way he tried to
argue being at the symmetric point may
not be the preferred thing to do
and this idea of spontaneous symmetry
breaking is something we just
used today to describe many physical
phenomena so spontaneous symmetry
breaking
is the feature that we now use but this
idea was there
thousands of years ago but applied
incorrectly to the physical world but
now we are using it so these ideas are
coming back in different forms
so i agree very much that the thought
process is more important and these
ideas are more interesting than the
actual applications that people may find
today
did they use the language of symmetry
and the symmetry breaking and
spontaneous symmetry that's really
interesting yes
because like i could see a conception of
the universe that kind of tends towards
perfect symmetry and is stuck there like
they
not stuck there but achieves that
optimal and stays there
the idea that you would spontaneously
break out of symmetry
uh like have these perturbations like
jump out of symmetry and
back that's not that's a really
difficult idea
to uh to load into your head like where
where does that come from and and then
and then the idea that
you may not be at the center of the
universe
right that is a really tough idea right
so symmetry sometimes is an explanation
of being at the symmetric point is
sometimes a simple explanation of many
things like
if you have a ball a
circular ball then the bottom of it is
the lowest point so if you put a you
know pebble or something it will slide
down and go there at the bottom and
stays there
at the symmetric point because the
preferred point the lowest energy point
but if that same symmetric circular ball
that you had had the
bump on the on the bottom the bottom
might not be at the center it might be
on a circle on the table yeah
in which case the pebble would not end
up at the center will be the lower
energy point it's symmetrical but
it breaks the symmetry once it picks a
point on that circle
so so we can have symmetry reasoning for
where things end up or
symmetric breakings like this example
would suggest
you